I'd like to introduce the senior  director of the Academy's mid-career  Talent Development Joan y  [Applause]  hi I oversee the nickel fellowships and  screenwriting competition which  discovered these wonderful new  screenwriters that we met tonight  this competition would not be possible  without the dedicated hard work of my  team Chris cartji and Alex Payne thank  you  my gratitude also goes to the many  departments and countless colleagues  that collaborated with us to pull off  the celebration thank you to you all  I would like to ask any nickel fellows  who are with us tonight to please stand  well all nickel fellows please stand  with us  once a nickel fellow always a nickel  fellow to our newest fellows the people  you see standing with you are just some  members of the larger nickel tribe you  are now a part of welcome to the family  [Applause]  [Music]